uh jeff bezos is here oh
wow great actor
and he's got cash when he writes a check
the bank bounce
like jeff bezos is so rich he got
divorced
and he's still the richest man in the
world
[Laughter]
he saw a marriage story and thought it
was a comedy
uh steve do you have anything you want
to add about mr bezos no i like getting
my packages on time
trump i remember
when he said if you're a billionaire
women let you grab them by the [__]
checks out i don't don't get me wrong i
know there's women in here who are like
that's [__] up that's [__]
i would never allow that and to you i
would say
you've never met a billionaire
that's got nothing to do with you you're
out there getting fingered by
thousands
it's a different demographic
[Music]
and frankly i agree with you a thousand
there should ask you permission
before he puts his minimum wage fingers
in your [__] that's disgusting that's
why your [__] smells like wendy's
but a billionaire let him grab your
[__]
a billionaire grabs your [__] that's
the best thing that's happened to you in
your life
you're gonna sue that guy and now you're
a millionaire
fastest million dollars you've ever made
okay you know how many billionaires
there are in the world
it's like a hundred any one of them
could grab my
dick anywhere
let bill gates walk up to me right now
grab my dick i'll grab his wrists and
hold that [__] down
yeah bill i'll show you microsoft
look
[Applause]
this is cool so the news we're going to
talk about that's right we have business
news facebook founder mark zuckerberg
is facing a 1 billion dollar a 1 billion
tax bill this year now that's he pays a
billion dollars
in taxes and tax that's uh
that's a lot of money good problem to
have right tom
that's not bad goddamn absolutely a
billion dollars a billion dollars that's
more than my dad made in his lifetime
[Laughter]
unbelievable this guy's a carpenter
about that how old is this guy
i i don't know i think he's in his
mid-20s maybe yeah
and most of these i think i feel these
rich kids are unknown
yeah you know i mean like he's known
because of that movie yeah
but uh but i think most of them i think
that these super billionaire guys keep
themselves unknown
so we don't find out and go to their
house oh yeah
he's probably not the real you know he's
just sort of like the
you know there's there's there's much
bigger billions do you think there's
bigger guys i think there's there yeah
they're living on an island somewhere
yeah yeah they're just running
everything because when you hear about
it how much money
the richest guys have yeah nobody i mean
i mean
i know sandler he doesn't have nearly
that much money you know what i mean and
he's the richest guy he's super rich
if you're if you're if you were if you
had you know you probably don't want to
make a big show if you're
not yeah they probably have the cure for
cancer they're probably selling all the
you know all the drugs that we're all
taking all the drugs they're selling all
that stuff they've got all the cures
they're living on an island
well those are the [__] that
[__] introduced crack into my
neighborhood
last month do you have a crack problem
[__] introduce crack into the
neighborhood really
and what they don't tell you about crack
is god damn it's good
yeah where in your neighborhood there's
a correction
you can just step out the front door now
and there's a crack readily available
now well i
sell it yeah so but i i'm using so much
of it now yeah
but i'm still getting fat yeah well
still quite uh
you don't have any now do you any any
crack now oh no i don't know
well after you do it for a while you do
not share yeah
learn that one the heart you go but
meanwhile you're not out
and you do everyone else's crack with
them yeah and then you sneak off into
the bathroom do your own crap right
yeah just good idea yeah
morphine's good too there's one called
crocodile have you ever heard of
crocodile no i
haven't in international news
bill gates i was reading about bill
gates owner of microsoft he has
85 billion dollars wow here's a guy who
could lose
80 billion dollars and still have five
[__] billion
i would lose it really fast because i
would do stupid [__] with the money all
the time
like one you know what you could do with
85 you could you could buy every
baseball team
and make them all wear dresses for like
three billion and still have 82 [__]
billion
how do you not do that how do you resist
i would do [__] like that every day
[Applause]
one day i'd go out buy all the pants in
the world every pair of pants
and just burn them [__] everybody no
more pants
start over with making pants they're all
gone
i think all the time about [__] i would
do with 85 billion though man you could
pull [__] that would last years for that
i always think about what i would do
i was thinking about this all day today
because i'm a loser i got nothing to do
i was thinking about how i would open a
chain of pet food stores
all over the country and it would be
called [__] ass pet [__] that would
be the name of it
but it would be like walmart just huge
[__] ass pet [__] big yellow sign
people working in there rudya you walk
in there like get the [__] out of here
you
idiot they don't even let you come in
and if you get past that
dog food cost a million dollars for one
can that's the price
[__] you you don't like it [__] screw
it's [__] ass pet [__]
[Music]
and and and also if you come in we'll
[__] your pet that's the rule
you don't even have to bring it we'll
fight it and [__] it
that's the way it's gonna be nobody will
ever
ever spend a dime as shit-ass pet
[__] but i will keep it open for
years and decades and
never close keep expanding like we're
doing great
a new one every day next to another one
just surround every starbucks with five
shit-ass pencils
all facing each other
just to enjoy people going what the [__]
why doesn't it close
jesus that place
sucks man that is the worst pet store
i'm not paying a million dollars for a
can of dog food that's
clearly overpriced
[Applause]
and they [__] your pets that's not
appropriate to [__] people's pets come
on
but they've been open for 50 years now
damn those [__] ass pet [__] people
i've been seeing some [__] go out of
business it's disturbing but i think
it's because of amazon not because of
covet
you know when you see like a big like
superstore
go out of business you're just like uh
i thought you were the guys that were
[__] had their foot in the back of
everybody's neck isn't that amazing
though
you got to hand it to that besos guy the
hell his name
is um
pesos right something like that whatever
bezos pesos
i like basils we'll go with basils right
that [__] guy took an online store
and just blew past
[__] target walmart
sears penney
right all the super stores sorry had to
go back there for a while
child world toys r he gets guy [__]
blew past all of them
you don't even know where his story
where is his store where is all the
stuff
where the [__] i can literally get
anything from a kid's bicycle
to like a [__] scale to weigh cocaine
if i'm a drug dealer
from these [__] people
to a refrigerator a a [__] tarp for
your car
what else do you want huh you want that
little thing that you know kids play
with behind the door then the little
[__] thing that
stops the door from hitting the wall
they got that [__] too they got it all
they got they literally
they have everything
all right and then you combine the fact
that they turned our food
into poison all right and you got these
people just like on the sugar and salt
right
just [__] mainline in it you know
they're having a light night which means
they're just eating the vanilla cookies
you know what i mean because it seems
like you know it's almost like a lighter
leaf
cigar you know or maybe it's racist
like why do the oreos have to be the bad
ones bill
you know considering you're you're
you're now
in a racially mixed family unit here
you'd think that you'd be a little nicer
about oreos
um these [__] people they're sitting
at home
all right and they're eating cookies and
[__] pre-made rotisserie chickens
lamb and garlic right they get the salt
through the roof then they just start
shoving those sleeves of cookies in
right
the keebler elf [__] and all of that and
then what used to happen is late at
night
they needed to go out and buy something
which was that website people at walmart
or something like that and just the way
these people were dressed
the gang green the broken flip-flops
the the the wasted potential
that you just saw just shuffling
into these [__] superstores all right
and then this website website started up
this page
people at walmart or something like that
and they shamed these [__] people
you know and i think that bezos besos
guys he goes you know what i think
that there is a market out there
for people that just want to keep buying
[__] but don't want to be seen
buying it talking about the agoraphobic
obese people
that on odd days of the month eat the
regular oreos
on the even days they eat the blonde
oreos and on holidays they eat double
stuff
and these [__] people need pocketees
they need flat screen tvs they need all
of this [__] and this [__] guy
started a business
to cater to people and now these people
don't have to go out in public right
you know it's like that movie precious i
was talking about right all these
precious people
going into the [__] walmarts getting
shamed
you know wearing some giant purple
something
people call them barney the dinosaur
they don't have to do anymore they can
just [__] stay home
from the comfort of their own home they
can order whatever they want and because
this basos guy saw this [__]
before the walmart people they were just
like hey these [__] people there we
crushed their downtown we crushed
their mom and pop stores we buried them
we buried them the way the white man
buried the native americans that were
here first we continued it on now we
buried the barriers
who can bury us we have 900 000
square [__] feet and guess what he's
gonna turn that place into the
bezos guy is going to turn all those
[__] walmarts
into uh uh the most epic [__] uh
maybe skateboard parks or laser tag
laser tag skateboard
something or other like i don't know
what you're gonna do with all of those
things
they're all going to go under there's
not a goddamn thing anybody can do about
it unless somebody
puts down those oreo cookies
and figures out where that [__] guy
lives and takes him out
doesn't take him out like i don't want
to encourage anybody do anything crazy
you know what i mean
just do give him the ddt some sort of
wrestling finishing move
you know if you can get your [__]
flabby leg up that high